how's it going everybody it's Warren and
a discovery has been made that could
potentially save Tony Stark in the
Avengers end game trailer we learned
that Tony is lost in space and is dying
he ran out of food and he ran out of
water and he's about to run out of
oxygen so judging by what they showed us
in the trailer time is running out for
Tony but could one of Rockets tools that
could be on the ship actually save Tony
Stark I'll break it down for you in this
video also I'm giving away a life-size
Infinity Gauntlet all you have to do to
enter for your chance to win is be
subscribed to my channel like this video
and comment down below with your
thoughts and your favorite superhero so
why is the Bennett R which is star-lord
ship which is the current ship that Tony
is on losing oxygen the ship should
regulate and produce oxygen but it's
clearly not and this is most likely due
to the fact that the ship is probably
damaged the ship was on Titan and Thanos
did throw parts of a moon at Titan it's
actually kind of a miracle that the ship
is even still intact but with Thanos
throwing parts of the moon at Titan most
of the surface was destroyed or damaged
and the benatar was most likely damaged
as well in fact I wouldn't be surprised
if Tony Stark actually had to use some
of his Nano bites to help fix the ship
this would explain why Tony only has a
helmet he had to use some of his Nano
bites to make the ship functional but
even with Tony trying to repair the ship
it's still probably pretty damaged which
is why it's probably leaking oxygen but
what if there was a tool that could help
completely repair the ship the ship
could regulate oxygen again and Tony
Stark wouldn't died due to lack of
oxygen well as it turns out there might
be something on the ship that could help
Tony do just that reddit user Naughty
Dog's has reminded everybody that rocket
has a tool that can repair the ship we
saw him do it in guardians of the galaxy
vol 2 one fan took to Twitter and asked
James Gunn if Rocket had created this
tool or if it was a standard tool for
ships James Gunn replied by saying he
didn't invent it but it's expensive
it keeps the entire ship in his memory
and can recreate all of it or just the
damaged parts similar to an incredibly
sophisticated 3d printer it takes
expertise
time and patience to employ Tony Stark
is a genius so he could probably figure
it out
nebula is on the ship as well and she
might know how to use it the tool isn't
exactly small so it wouldn't be a tool
that rocket would carry on him at all
times so it's most likely on the ship so
if the reason why the ship is losing
oxygen is actually due to the fact that
the ship is damaged then Tony Stark's
problems could be solved if he finds
this tool and again the ship is most
likely damaged because dana's threw a
huge chunk of a moon at Titan which the
benatar was on so it most likely got
damaged but let me know what you all
think do you think that this tool could
possibly help save Tony Stark or do you
think something else let me know in the
comments down below and don't forget to
subscribe comment and like the video so
you can enter the giveaway for your
chance to win d Infinity Gauntlet and so
you can stay up to date on everything
related to Avengers endgame as always
thank you all so much for watching
woof woof
[Music]
you